مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيد نفع
[موسيقى]
الاخبار مقلقه سمعناها على مدار اليومين
الماضيين من فرنسا حول اتهام نجم منتخب
المغرب واحد افضل الاظهره في العالم اشرف
حكيمي
بالاقتصاد للاسف الان هل هذه التراب
حقيقيه ولا لا هذا امر بيرجع للقضاء هو
بيحدده ولكن حتى الان اللي بنعرفه عن
الموضوع هي معلومات من الادعاء العام في
اللي هي المنطقه اللي تم تقديم الشكوى
فيها
والان تجرى التحقيقات من جانب مكتب
الادعاء العام بشان هذه الاتهامات
اشرف حكيمي بعد ما قدم سنه رائعه جدا مع
منتخب بلده وصل المنتخب المغرب لنصف نهائي
كاس العالم 2022
وساهم طبعا بشكل كبير بوصول المغرب لربع
النهائي بركضه الفرنكه اللي كانت امام
اسبانيا بتذكرها وطبعا عاش فتره لا باس
بها ايضا مع باريس سان جيرمان موسم الماضي
وخلال موسم الحالي الان يواجه مرحله اعتقد
انه راح تكون صعبه شوي حتى يثبت براءته من
التهامي الموجهه له هل كل ما وجهت تهمه
لشخص بتكون صحيحه اكيد لا لانه مثل ما
شفنا رونالدو اتهم ايضا بتهمه مماثله وكان
في يعني ادعاءات انه هو اعتدى على فتاه
معينه بامريكا عام 2009 ولكن تم تبرئته من
الموضوع وتم دفع تعويض له بسبب هذه القضيه
بشكل عام وبالتالي لا يمكن ان نتسرع ونذهب
الى الاحكام ونطلق الاستنتاجات ونبدا بانه
نشكل صوره نم طيه على اللاعب واللومو او
انه نعمل اي خطوه اتجاهه بهاي
محامي اشرف حكيمي اعطى تصريحات لصحيفه
الفرنسيه وكان واضح جدا انه اللاعب ينفي
اي ارتكاب اي خطا او ارتكاب اي جرم في هذا
الصدد وهو الان هادئ وتحت تصرف القضاء متى
ما طلبوا القضاء راح يكون موجود وراح
يساعد ايضا بالتحقيقات وبالتالي ما عنده
اي مشكله راح يكون متعاون جدا مع السلطات
الفرنسيه فمن جهه اللاعب سمعنا التصريح
انه هو عم بينفي هاي الاتهامات وهذا امر
طبيعي طبعا ومن جهه الادعاء الفرنسي عم
بيعمل تحقيقاته وهذا كل اللي بنعرفه عن
القضيه حتى الان ما يرجوه طبعا كل محب
لكره القدم انه اشرف حكيمي يطلع بريء ولكن
في امور اهم من كره القدم ايضا وهي الامور
الانسانيه اللي لازم ناخذ لها اعتبار
اساسي ورئيسي قبل كل شيء اخر لذلك اذا كان
بريئا اشرف حكيمي من الاتهامات الموجهه له
راح تكون بالتاكيد اخبار ساره للجميع الان
كيف راح يمشي هاي المرحله اشرف بين ما
تبلش تبين التفاصيل الاخرى للقضيه هذا امر
يحتاج للكثير من الهدوء يحتاج للكثير من
التركيز داخل الملعب من جامبو ومن جانب
ايضا اداره باريس سان جيرمان لانه هاي
القضيه ممكن تعمل مشكله كبيره جدا تاثر
على مسيره الفريق الفارسي بهذا الموسم
بشكل تام ان كان بدور الابطال ولا بالدوري
الفرنسي وهو وضعه اصلا بدوري الابطال مش
كثير منيح وبالتالي قضيه مثل هاي هي اخر
شيء ممكن يحتاجه الفريق بهذا التوقيت من
الموسم احتواء الموقف بالطريقه الصحيحه من
جانب اداره الفريق البريزي اللي بالمناسبه
حاولت سياره من التواصل معها للحصول على
تعليق على هذه الانباء ولكن ما كان في
تعليق حتى اللحظه من جانب اداره باريس سان
جيرمان ولكن اسلوب او طريقه الاحتواء هي
اللي راح تقرر مدى تاثير هذه القضيه على
مستوى باريس سان جيرمان خلال الموسم
الحالي هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه اليوم بعض
الصافره حتى نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل كونوا
بالف خير